the program that we developed has been
tested
and uh piloted in many different
settings including the louisiana
biomedical research network
uh different programs like georgetown
university systems medicine
as well as universities around the world
and so as a result
we have received a lot of feedback that
we've incorporated into the way that the
training program has been structured
but our company doesn't just focus on
training itself
and so as a part of various different
research projects and collaborations
we have been privileged to work on a
number of research
application development for different
areas that i will be actually talking
about in just a few minutes
one of these has to do with the
integration of omix data in a variety of
big data research projects as you can
see here this is integration
of different types of data phenotypic
data and data about omics
analysis we've worked on a number of
collaborations for biomarker discovery
in real world evidence collection and
clinical trial projects
as well as projects for small molecule
screening
and this hit to lead optimization
from libraries of
small molecules and so as a result of
this kind of research experience we
really developed
this kind of a data science program that
is intended to give an opportunity for
students that come from high school
undergraduate as well as postgraduate
level
teachers and faculty at high schools
colleges and universities as well as
researchers like biologists and
clinicians at research labs and
biotechnology companies
an opportunity to master tools and
skills
that are required for effective
data-driven
research projects and so to speak a
little bit more about the way that this
program is organized i want to give you
a background
on what omics logic as a training portal
really is
so now that you've all signed up to the
omics logic portal
let me introduce what the programs
courses and different training resources
that we
have how are they organized and and
what's the difference between them
so the goal of our mixed logic programs
is to provide training in bioinformatics
and i'll talk a little bit about the
relationship between bioinformatics and
data science
in a little bit and the important part
of it is
to enable independent research guided by
mentors and peer examples so it's more
than just a collection of courses
it's also a community and
this community is shared has a shared
passion for data-driven research
and an appreciation of citizen science
and so what's important here is that
this is a community where you can
kind of get to know other people you can
collaborate with other people on
research projects
and a critical part of that is
essentially training
and one of the challenges that we see is
that
many people from different backgrounds
have
to apply different types of data science
skills
to develop independent research projects
using latest technology in life and data
sciences
and so one of the programs that we've
developed as a result of this kind of
vision for this onyx logic community
is a program on omix logic data science
and this kind of a program combines
resources online asynchronously
and in a blended fashion to
empower different types of people with
different backgrounds
to learn about statistical analysis and
machine learning experimental design and
technical variation
that is to found an exploratory data
analysis as well as to apply
data mining tools for meaningful for
finding meaningful patterns and
associations
and study complex biological systems
using big data
so this program on data science combines
a number of different important aspects
including
different types of omics data steps for
exploratory data analysis and
processing data analysis for big data
integration and mining
and the application of these different
tools
to different types of research questions
so
today's webinar is going to focus on a
number of these aspects which
we will do an introduction to data
science and bioinformatics so what's the
relationship between data science and
bioinformatics
and a little overview of data processing
cleaning and exploration
how to do that and what are some of the
tools that we will cover in this program
the application of data science in
biomedicine
introduction to machine learning
algorithms for next generation
sequencing data
the application of data mining and
integration for multi-omics or
x-omics integration and then i will pass
it on to our next speaker to talk about
deep learning
natural language processing and image
analysis and how those
are important in this domain of
biomedical data
analysis so let me first start by
speaking about the relationship between
data science
and bioinformatics so what is data
science really
data science is data storage
organization
retrieval including application of
different data formats
biological specialization right if we
talk about
the domain where we apply data science
in the context of biomedical data
science
right this includes biological research
but it could include
many other different domains right and
so here
what we all can appreciate is
the similarity between data science and
bioinformatics because
all the same different aspects of data
science
if they are exclusively applied to
biological data
now we can call that bioinformatics and
so when you think about bioinformatics
really
that talks about different types of
information
technologies apply to biological or
biomedical research
and so one of the differences where we
see the importance of these kinds of
skills
in information management in statistical
analysis
and machine learning is the specific
application of these methods
to major impactful questions
in biomedical data and so two main areas
that i want to focus on today
are drug discovery and clinical trials
because i think that
in both of these areas there is a major
change or a paradigm shift that is going
on and many of you are probably aware of
these
transformations but they really require
this change in thinking about the way
data
is used for these two problems so what
is the challenge
in drug discovery one of the major
challenges in drug discovery is the time
how much time does it take to get from
a number of potentially active compounds
to a compound that could actually be
brought to market
through the different stages of
commercialization of that compound and
that goes through
stages of research and discovery where
multiple compounds are analyzed
and several are selected to then hit to
lead optimization
and then through several stages of
clinical trials
and so the clinical trials area is the
second
major area where this transformation is
quite
obvious in clinical trials you have to
design a specific process by which that
compound that is not toxic and
is efficacious can go through several
stages of validation
and that requires selection of the right
types of candidate patients
the right kinds of indicators and the
right kind of validation for
a certain level of efficacy for those to
proceed
from stage one to stage three and then
to be observed in post-market
surveillance to understand
how other types of patients are
responding to this type of treatment
so these two areas are very important in
the area of data science for biomedical
data
and those are some of the things that we
will focus on in
this program now importantly i think
there's
a huge opportunity in regards to this
kind of
big data because a lot of this type of
data is actually
available on publicly available
repositories
and not only is it available we know
that since this
pandemic the amount of data is actually
growing and so this accelerated pace
of availability of big data that is now
accessible to anyone who is interested
in asking research questions about this
type of data
provides us also with an opportunity to
develop these kinds of training programs
where instead of giving you test
examples we can actually
leverage some of these real-life project
examples
from the research and clinical areas to
provide you with an immersive
experience where you can apply specific
types of data science
tools and methods to ask questions about
these kinds of data sets
so the first challenge having this kind
of availability of data the first
challenge that i see
is the challenge of data structures
how to clean process and normalize
the huge variety of data types
that is available and these include
imaging data
streaming data like emr clinical data
omics data chemical data phenotypic data
all have to be prepared so that they are
structured
and available for the layer of analytics
that we would like to apply in a
meaningful way to these types of data
sets
and potentially even integrate them to
find associations between
the phenotypic data and the different
types of omics data that are available
and so one of the things that our
company has been focused on
is making the omics data simplified
democratized and more clearly understood
by
the millions of researchers that are out
there trying to
understand the molecular drivers of
disease
as well as molecular indicators of
treatment efficacy
and so the first challenge in omics data
that i see
is the variability of data types and
what do they actually represent
so since they provide a very detailed
view
of molecular changes and activities
inside the cell we're talking at a
subcellular precision
that comes with a lot of challenges and
so what are these omics data types
one type of omics is phenomics where we
can look at
cell morphology and characterize
different cell shapes
and activities we can look at genomic
data which is essentially variation
at the dna code we can look at
epigenomic data which essentially tells
us about
subgenomic regulation so regulation that
is not
inside the dna code itself but provides
a layer of modification
like uh data sets like whole genome by
sulfide sequencing
and chromatin immunoprecipitation where
we can
understand different types of variations
transcriptomic data the result of
expression of mrna and downstream
modification of that
mrna and so as you can see these data
sets
are very different they're different
because they describe these different
aspects of the same biological phenomena
but using different technologies and so
the first part of this program we will
do a little overview of how to process
and structure such data so that it is
ready for integration and so here we
will
look at several different examples of
genomic data like whole exome sequencing
and whole genome sequencing
epigenome genomic data like dna
methylation
and gypsy transcriptomic data analysis
for single cell and bulk rna sequencing
as well as proteomic and metabolomic
data so
all of them coming from the biological
material and being processed into a
structured
data set and so now once the data set
is structured now we enter the domain of
data science and in this domain of data
science now we can
operate with the same statistical
data exploration and classification
methods
that allow us to ask questions about
relationships
of these different and distinct data
types
that describe different types of
biological phenomena
but also different types of biomedical
applications
about recruitment of patients for
clinical trials
about what drives disease progression
and about what kinds of treatment
targets are there available
to be able to intervene in a specific
malignant process
and so as an example we can take a look
at
how this is changing the way we can
treat patients
ultimately when we generate new data
instead of coming as a new set of data
we essentially see that as an integrated
uh data set combined with other existing
samples that allow us to ask
questions about population similar
patients patients that have
benefited from different types of
treatments and
the features that define those patients
or different types of
markers that we could rely on to
optimize
future treatment so onyx logic
is essentially a complete roadmap
for data science in application to
biomedical research data
that will talk about finding data sets
exploring and visualizing those data
sets
understanding different types of
research methodologies
and gain insight and understanding
looking at some of those questions that
are being
asked by top medical